Оце наша, вибачте, шлюбна фотографія.
Фати нема, рюшей нема, квітів нема,обручок нема.
Нічого нема.  Ось таке у нас було демократичне чоловіче весілля.
Але це було круто.
Кияни Ігор Старіков та Ігор Єрмаков у Європейському Союзі - зареєстровані цивільні партнери.
Фактично - подружжя.
Розписалися чоловіки у 2014 році у Берліні. На той час обидва Ігорі вже 10 років були разом.
У багатьох країнах Євросоюзу зареєстроване партнерство дає чоловікам чимало переваг.
Для них це важливо - подружжя має туристичний бізнес та нерухомість у Чехії.
Це абсолютно рівноправний до шлюбу документ.
Всі права, які мають і гетеросексуальні пари. Всі. Абсолютно.
Спільне майно, захист прав при розлученні - не дай, Боже, до того дійде, -
захист прав одного з партнерів, якщо інший помирає, доступ в лікарню.
Це абсолютно нормальний, робочий документ - зокрема для чехів.
І коли нотаріус нам реєструвала компанію, вона вже мала цей документ на руках,
вона оком не моргнула -  зареєструвала її як сімейну фірму.
Натомість з точки зору українських законів Ігорі - абсолютно чужі одне одному люди.
Попри 16 років проживання разом та офіційну реєстрацію партнерства в країні ЄС.
Як ділити спільне майно у разі розлучення - незрозуміло.
А на спадщину зможуть претендувати небажані родичі.
Нам конче потрібно, щоб в Україні можна було захистити свої права.
Назвіть це як хочете - соціальне партнерство, шлюб. Мені все одно.
Просто дайте мені можливість захистити своє право на щастя і на спільне життя.
Я не збираюся організовувати шоу, я не збираюся іти під вінець -
мені це не потрібно. Я хочу, щоб у мене був документ, який би визнавався всіма судами,
всіма нашими соціальними, медичними та державними органами.
Щоб в мене не тикали пальцями і не казали: "Пшол вон, ізвращєнець".
Через те, що геї та лесбійки в Україні не можуть узаконити свої стосунки,
вони позбавлені базових прав, які мають гетеросексуальні пари.
Заповнити законодавчу прогалину нещодавно спробував київський адвокат Артем Афян.
Він розробив партнерський договір для одностатевих пар.
При цьому, каже юрист, сам він до ЛГБТ не належить,
а захищати їхні права його багато років тому мотивував комуніст-гомофоб.
По телевізору якось депутат від Комуністичної партії України
говорив про те, що ніколи на території України такі шлюби не будуть визнані.
І мене зачепили власне дві речі: те, що така некрасива людина іншим людям каже,
які їм союзи укладати, а з іншого боку слово "ніколи".
Я подумав: "А чого він так каже - ніколи?" Начебто він це контролює.
І я як юрист задався ціллю - цікаво, а чи можна відтворити шлюбний союз
за допомогою цивільноправових механізмів, тобто контрактових конструкцій, довіреностей.
Партнерський договір, який розробив Артем Афян, дозволяє певною мірою врегулювати питання щодо користування спільним майном,
а також його розподілу в разі розставання.
Також договір встановлює обов'язок дбати про дитину партнера або партнерки,
якщо вона залишиться без опікунів. Щоправда, визнає Артем Афян, цей документ,
навіть із печаткою нотаріуса - далеко не шлюб.
Цей договір не є альтернативою шлюбу в таких частинах: по-перше, це податкове зобов'язання.
Під час спадкування між особами, які перебувають у шлюбі, застосовується нульова ставка -
договір цього не може забезпечити. Договір не може надати можливості
відмовитись від свідчень проти партнера у кримінальному провадженні,
і третє - договір не може гарантувати права на усиновлення.
Те, що встановлює цей договір - це обов'язок піклуватися про дитину.
Односторонній обов'язок. На нього можуть не зважати органи опіки. Тобто це не означає, що ця особа
обов'язково отримає цю дитину, але тим не менш вже якийсь зв'язок з дитиною встановлено документально.
При цьому саме останній пункт є найважливішим для багатьох гомосексуальних пар, які виховують дітей,
каже підприємиця Олеся Соломіна, яка має сина і доньку.
Олеся та її партнерка стали першою парою, яка підписала партнерський договір.
І якщо у дітей Олесі є біологічний батько, який також про них піклується,
діти багатьох інших пар не захищені у випадку смерті батька або матері.
Є ситуації, коли батьки людей, які перебувають в одностатевих стосунках,
ставляться до цього погано, часто відмовляються від дітей - і таким чином у дітей цих пар немає бабусь і дідусів.
І найстрашніше, що в разі смерті біологічного батька/матері куди потрапить ця дитина?
В цьому договорі написано волевиявлення одног партнера батька чи матері дитини
в разі його смерті подбати про дитину, щоб вона не потрапила в дитячий будинок.
Тобто, цей договір є приводом для суду у разі смерті одного з партнерів.
Це великий крок, далі повинні бути прецеденти. Цей договір дає право судитися за опікунство.
Тим часом комплексно вирішити проблеми одностатевих пар могло б запровадження інституту цивільного партнерства,
яке було б хоч і не рівнозначною, але все ж альтернативою шлюбу,
що визначений у Конституції України як союз чоловіка і жінки.
Законопроєкт про цивільне партнерство, створення якого координувала Українська гельсінська спілка з прав людини,
наразі готовий на 85 відсотків, каже Святослав Шеремет,
співавтор законопроєкту та координатор з політики та законодавства національного ЧСЧ-консорціуму.
ЧСЧ - це абревіатура на позначення "чоловіків, сексуальність яких спрямована на чоловіків".
У документі йдеться зокрема про керування спільним майном, спадщиною,
право ухвалювати медичні рішення за партнера або партнерку,
якщо він або вона ці рішення приймати не може.
А також - про опіку над дітьми. Про усиновлення наразі взагалі не йдеться.
Скажімо, є пара жінок, у кожної з яких є одна-дві дитини,
і сукупно, скажімо, у них троє чи четверо дітей.
Вони між собою в близьких стосунках.
Ми розуміємо, що де-факто це багатодітна сім’я,
а з точки зору закону - ні.
Відповідно, ця родина позбавлена законних і хороших пільг,
якими можуть користуватися багатодітні сім’ї.
Далі. Виникає питання: якщо у мене є діти і в мене є партнер,
то в яких правових стосунках мій партнер перебуває щодо моїх дітей?
Ми маємо відповідь: другий партнер чи друга партнерка
в таких ситуаціях набувають - увага - не батьківських прав,
які є довічними, а опікунських прав, піклувальних прав про дитину.
І хоча поки невідомо, коли законопроєкт буде внесено на розгляд Верховної Ради
і чи знайдеться достатньо голосів для його підтримки, представники ЛГБТ-спільноти впевнені:
впровадження можливості узаконити одностатеві стосунки в Україні - питання часу.
Адже, як свідчать дослідження, ставлення суспільства до ЛГБТ поступово покращується.
Це визнають і представники спільноти, з яким спілкувалася DW.
Прайди стають все більш велелюдними і все більше пар геїв та лесбійок відкрито заявляють про себе.